[Music]
holding you ever since I've known you
Joe I couldn't help it Amy producing and
directing all these lovely girls like
what was it like getting this everyone
together and like telling this like
amazing female forward story well was it
sort of astonishing about it and I still
kind of can't believe I can't believe we
got away with it I can't believe anybody
let us do this I can't believe this
studio got behind it in the way that it
did because not only is it is it a film
this this epic story about sisters and
lives of girls and women and and and
what's more domestic about that with the
men that they know but but it's also a
period piece it's also based on a novel
this is exactly the kind of movie that
nobody makes anymore and nobody wants to
finance and nobody thinks there's an
audience for the fact that we did it and
we did it here in Concord on location on
film with this great of a cast I feel
like we got to steal something from the
world it feel like we got away with
something well it's pretty amazing and I
will say like I was saying down there
like it's this generation's version like
every generation should get their
version and it's amazing and in every
version I'm sorry Lori is how do I put
it the guy that would leave you on
ghosts you on tinder yeah
ghosting on text ghost on tinder Laura's
not even on tinder Lori's like swiping
for his friends don't go out with and
then I feel like loves people too much
and then it's like like you're like go
home go home it's hard it somebody ate
something yet was asking great that
earlier to imagine to temporizing some
these characters and not not too narrow
not to make it a narrative but just in
real life I think we might be one of the
trickiest maybe maybe not even yeah yeah
he might be actually you know what maybe
he's barefoot her babies were Brian
Krakow the one that gets left on the
bicycle and somebody said with the wit
this winged event we did they were like
I we feel that Laurie is the og ally and
I was like it's true from women like
like key holds the space he wants to be
part of the club and he's not gonna
interrupt and he'll do a funny voice and
oh pretend to be another person like
he's like he'll go in with everything
he's got to be part of no I feel like
but I do feel like Laurie's a new vision
of masculinity and and it's emotional
it's connected and it's egalitarian and
I feel like Timothy is an emerging young
person is also doing that I like that
face it one thing that that that I might
be able to quick enough just you know
that's very nice and yet I do feel like
a part of this in a small part in a good
way in that in in fairness and in honor
of Gary she flushed out this role for
this guy I think Bray significant lean
and and yet he's just a human and we're
all just humans and that's what's so
awesome about this movie and again
that's making MD sales pitch but this is
like this is a this is a were the real
things with my favorite things when I
talk to people about the movie now and
wasn't an anxiety about my I made it
felt like an obvious thing to say -
Greta before we start making it which is
well they've made other version so you
know ours is gonna be worthy right and I
like that when I talk to people now it's
not even it doesn't even come
and I love or respect to all the
versions yeah but it doesn't even come
up now because it's it's not even like
will let's still debate this cuz really
this is its own and did you see okay I
guess you can't say to see their but I
can say this do you see what Jillian
Armstrong said yeah it's awesome that's
awesome
no one is obliged to say that no one
needs to say that and it's a moving
thing that tweet like moved me and so
weird thing to say that three even feels
like an empty thing to say I don't if
you sell but but the thing that you said
at the end the hashtag whatever it's
like you know it's as Greta said before
this thing this got made and that's
amazing and it's a not a miracle but
it's a great thing I made in itself and
yet in oh woe is us way I also see the
whatever yeah I intend to make my own
way in the world no one makes their own
way least of all a woman you'll need to
marry well you are not married no well
that's because I'm rich ladies all I
have to say is I love this cast I love
all of you guys and like with Meryl and
Emma produced by Amy directed by Greta
written by what was it like coming all
together and being sisters on this just
like amazing like female forward set so
incredibly supportive awesome
that was a good sisterhood I'd say I'm
just fun it was just like we just
massive a with all the time and poke fun
at each other I'm always I mean we're
behaving very well there but we're
usually like on top of each other
picking on each other whatever you know
and we had we had Laura as well as Greta
and Amy obviously we had Laura at the
helm just his someone that you know I
think we all look up to and she was this
incredible I mean they do and but she's
she's an incredible she's an incredible
woman to just bring us all together and
be such a good sort of role model for us
and she I do feel like a lot of the time
you really set the tone for the youngins
so yeah we were very lucky that's
beautiful and also I think we can all
agree it was an amazing set of men yeah
we had both crew and cast the most
amazing supportive
generous thoughtful men and I mean
wouldn't it be gorgeous to say something
that's female forward is this inclusive
space where everyone's in consideration
of each other I mean I totally could
have made Timmy like eye candy but she
gave him some good lines let's do that
he's great but I also want to ask you
sir she's like you have obviously very
close relationship with Greta working
with her Lady Bird in this but why do
you think she was perfect to sort of put
her spin on this because I heard Amy say
it's what punk-rock Shakespeare oh well
what's really interesting I only found
this out when we were doing press for
the film is that when Greta went into
Sony to pitch the movie she hadn't made
Lady Bird yet she wasn't this thing that
like everybody's sort of admired so much
and everyone wanted to work with her and
nobody knew how like hot a director she
was yet and she went in and she said to
me Little Women is very clearly about
art and money and a woman's relationship
to her and how you try and balance that
and especially now for all of us that's
such a relevant important sort of like
idea and and that's what she wanted this
movie to be about more than anything and
that was sort of the driving force and I
think that's really interesting to kind
of look at it from that angle and then I
think on top of that like her she's got
a very specific style of filmmaking she
has always known the type of filmmaker
that she is she knows what movie she
wants to make and I think her just even
like you know really sort of carefully
playing with like the timelines and how
there's these very late delicate sort of
connections between past and present
your childhood and who you are now like
it made it it made it something that was
just fresh and like you know we all knew
she was gonna do that because she's
smart eliza this is one of the more
bigger things that you've done what was
it like working with her as your first
role because she's like an actor's
director I think and I would imagine
that probably helps oh yeah for sure
Greta has this incredible sensibility
because she is an actor and she speaks
our language and it makes all the
difference
and you're working on this film it took
me a while to process that I was going
to be on this set and I felt like I had
a little bit up my belt but I knew I was
going to learn a lot on this set which I
did not just with the craft and with
filmmaking but just being surrounded by
these beautiful women and they're all
very strong-headed and they they know
what they want and I think they really
taught me to stand up for what I want
and I was only was 19 almost 21 so I
have to ask you guys about this fight I
have to talk about slap me Saoirse break
it down for us I actually was on the
phone to someone this morning they're
like is it true that that you got hit by
Saoirse before every scene and I was
like no I'm like because apparently you
asked her to hit you before every scene
I was like that's my boisterous loving
relationship as we all did on on the set
we were always on top of one another in
in the scenes and so it was just during
that one scene when I burned the book it
was like one of the last days shooting
as well and we just wanted to wrestle
and so we did on camera and it was
amazing it was really like and we were
all trainer five and a party and two
really brilliant dancer yeah it was just
incredible you made me actually like Amy
Amy is a hard character for most people
in the book and in previous iterations
but I have to ask both sides of a
married directorial couple have you made
your allegiances between Noah and Greta
like who are you gonna sit with up these
various award shows they both wore your
shirt I think I'm I'm now I think an
adoptive child and I'm you know being
hopefully very mindful of you know
honoring each parent
we're having the time of our life
[Music]